[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers ihnen
allen guten Abend Shalom und salam
würden sie im Nahen Osten sagen der
Friedensgruß in einer Region die mit
jeder Minute mehr auf einen Krieg
zusteuert der alle dort erfassen könnte
Israels Armee hat Ziele im Libanon
angegriffen nachdem von dort offenbar
mehrere bewaffnete nach Israel
eingedrungen waren den Gazastreifen will
Israel jetzt auch von Strom und
Wasserlieferungen abschneiden premier
Benjamin Netanjahu sagt Israels Antwort
auf den Angriff aus Gaza werde Zitat den
Nahen Osten Verändern der unvorstellbare
Terror mit dem Hamas die Israelis über
überzog hat Spuren hinterlassen die
nachwirken werden für Generationen
praktisch jede und jeder in Israel kennt
jemanden der ermordet wurde oder
verschleppt oder verwundet im
Krankenhaus liegt 300.000 Frauen und
Männer machen sich als Reservisten in
der Armee bereit für einen Einsatz mit
ungewissem Ausgang l walport aus Tel
Aviv massive Luftangriffe auf Ziele im
gazaastreifen die militärische Antwort
Israels auf die brutale Terrorattacke
der Hamas bei der 900 Israelis getötet
mehr als 130 als Geiseln verschleppt
wurden es ist vermutlich nur die erste
Stufe der angekündigten israelischen
Vergeltung aber die Auswirkungen auf die
palästinensischen Bewohner des dicht
bevölkerten Gebiet sind spürbar fast 700
Tote heißt es in Gaza und am Abend droh
Hamas man werde für jeden weiteren
Angriff eine israelische Geisel töten
Psychoterror zugleich feuerte Hamas auch
heute wieder Raketen auf Israel ab
getroffen wurde unter anderem ein Haus
in askelon mehrere Menschen schwer
verletzt mein Auto mein Haus alles
zerstört eine schwierige Lage es ist
schrecklich massiv verstärkt das Militär
seine Kräfte entlang des Gazastreifens
Ortschaften werden weiter auf
möglicherweise versteckte Hamas
Terroristen durchkämmt der
Verteidigungsminister erklärt grimmig
man werde Gasa komplett abriegeln
keinen Strom mehr keine Lebensmittel
kein Wasser kein Brennstoff wir kämpfen
hier gegen Menschen die sich wie Tiere
Benehmen beunruhigende Meldungen auch
aus Nordisrael in Feuergefechten mit
hisboll sein vier Angreifer getötet
worden heißt es Regierungschef netanahu
spricht am Abend zur Nation appelliert
an die Opposition einer
Notstandsregierung
beizutreten es geht hier um unsere
Heimat
wir wussten immer schon wer Hamas ist
jetzt weiß es die ganze Welt sie sind
keinen Deut besser als die is
Terroristen und wie den is werden wir
auch sie besiegen dieser widerwärtige
Feind wollte Krieg er wird Krieg
bekommen in der Not rückt das Land
zusammen viele Orts Spenden Bürger Blut
um die Versorgung der Verwundeten
sicherzustellen und Initiativen wie hier
in Tel Aviv organisieren Hilfe für
Familien in den betroffenen
Dörfern meine Tochter ist beim Militär
mein Mann wurde gerade als Reservist
eingezogen alle helfen wo sie
können es ist eine Möglichkeit mit dem
tiefen Schock der vergangenen Tage
zurechtzukommen und wir bringen auch
heute unseren Israel Korrespondenten mit
dazu Michael beverunge ist live in
askelon Israel vor der Notaufnahme eines
Krankenhauses dort guten Abend Michael
wie sieht denn die aktuelle
Sicherheitslage aus können die Israelis
jetzt sicher sein dass keine Hamas
terrortrups mehr unterwegs
sind also absolut sicher wohl noch nicht
nach wie vor durch cemmen Soldaten das
Gebiet es gibt immer wieder Berichte von
einzelnen Feuergefechten aber im Großen
und Ganzen dürfte Israel die Kontrolle
über dieses vorgelagerte Gebiet die
Siedlungen vor dem Gazastreifen im
Grenzgebiet wiedererlät haben ohnehin
spielt das wahrscheinlich keine so große
Rolle mehr denn man hat bereits begonnen
viele Ortschaften genau in diesem Gebiet
zu evakuieren das heißt alle Bewohner
werden herausgebracht und das ist schon
eine klare Vorbereitung auf die
vorbestehende Offensive eine
Bodenoffensive Netanyahu hat heute auch
noch mal ganz klar gesagt nachdem dieses
Ziel der
Wiederherstellen der Kontrolle erreichte
ist das zweite große Ziel eine massive
noch nie daageesene offensivoperation
gegen die
das ist die alsat erwartete
Bodenoffensive und die scheint zumindest
bald
bevorzustehen Michael es ist ja ofbar
was ganz grundsätzliches kaputt gegangen
in Israel das Vertrauen auf die Armee
das Ende vieler Sicherheiten die dieses
Land und seine Bewohner immer ganz
besonders brauchten kann man das schon
beschreiben was das mit Israel
macht da ist obwohl immer wieder in den
vielen Kriegen und den vielen Verlusten
dieses Land tragen musste tatsächlich
mal wieder etwas zerbrochen aber die
Vergleiche sind schon monstruös es wird
nicht nur der Vergleich zum jomkipur
Krieg gezogen der die Israelis auch
überraschend getroffen hat es wird der
Vergleich zum Holocaust gezogen weil
noch nie anscheinend so viele Menschen
an einem Tag in Israel gestorben sind
und das macht schon deutlich welche
Dimension welches Ausmaß dieser brutale
Terrorakt für die Seele dieses Volkes
hat und natürlich ist der Ruf nach
Aufklärung extrem groß noch immer stehen
alle völlig fassungslos wie das
geschehen konnte davor und es wird die
Aufarbeitung geben man darf nicht
vergessen die Premierministerin im
jomkiurkrieg Golder Meir musste 1974
genau wegen dieses Versagens
zurücktreten und diese Abrechnung wird
sicherlich mit premier Netanyahu auch
noch erfolgen momentan geht es aber
erstmal darum die Reihen zu schließen
premier netanaho hat die Regierung wir
haben es die Opposition aufgefordert wir
haben es gehört in eine Regierung der
nationalen Einheit einzutreten das Land
zeigt jetzt erstmal Geschlossenheit aber
die Abrechnung dieser Frage die wird
noch kommen danke dir Michael für diese
Analyse niemand bleibt zurück das ist
das Versprechen dass Israels Armee ihren
Soldatinnen und Soldaten gibt als der
Rekrut gilat schalid vor Jahren von der
Hamas nach G entführt wurde tauschte
israels Regierung im Gegenzug für seine
Freilassung
1027 palästinensische Häftlinge aus 1027
für einen Soldaten jetzt hat Hamas 150
Menschen in ihrer Gewalt Soldaten Frauen
Kinder es ist ein Albtraum und er ist
nicht zu Ende Eltern erfahren aus dem
Internet in unbeschreiblichen Videoclips
dass ihre Kinder offenbar entführt
wurden oder brutal niedergeschossen
unzählige warten auf ein Lebens Zeichen
und darauf dass ihre Regierung sich bei
Ihnen meldet Christian von Rechenberg
berichtet jetzt über den schwärzesten
Tag in der Geschichte des kibutz beri
unmittelbar an der Grenze zum
Gazastreifen und das Ende aller
Gewissheiten sie haben dem Tod ins Auge
geblickt und sind ihm mit knapper Not
entkommen 400 Menschen die das Massaker
im kibutz berie miterlebten in Bunkern
unter Dauerfeuer stundenlang
benötigen Sie etwas oder kann ich Ihnen
helfen fragt der
freiwillige ja geben Sie mir mein kibutz
zurück sagt sie geben Sie mir meine
ermordeten Freunde zurück die Armee hat
sie einfach sterben
lassen mitten in
Israel es ist Samstag Morgen als die
Mörder kommen sie filmen sich wie sie in
berie brandschatzen verschleppen wahlos
töten vor die Tür tritt ist sofort tot
wer im Haus bleibt Schüsse Schreie
Einschläge sie haben uns abgeschlachtet
hingerichtet es sind so viele gewesen
mit so viel schweren Waffen wir saßen im
Bunker in der Falle wir wussten nicht
was gerade draußen passiert wir hatten
nur
WhatsApp das David Hotel e am Toten Meer
nun ihre Zuflucht weit weg von dem Ort
der nie mehr ein zu Hause sein kann wo
Psychologen und Helfer versuchen
abzulenken von der Hölle irgendwie für
ein paar wertvolle
Momente wir wurden irgendwann befreit
unter Beschuss meine Kinder waren so
tapfer wir haben ihnen die Augen
zugehalten weil wir über tote Menschen
steigen mussten und jetzt versuchen wir
unsere Gedanken zu ordnen überlegen wie
wir die Toten begraben wir haben ganze
ausgelöschte Familien wir haben Kinder
die ihre Eltern verloren haben wir haben
Eltern die keine Kinder mehr haben es
ist etwas zerbrochen in uns allen und
ich weiß nicht wie wir uns davon erholen
sollen die vielen Spenden haben
freiwillige gebracht Vertreter der
Behörde haben sie hier nicht gesehen sie
fühlen sich im Stich gelassen erst von
der Armee die zu spät kam und jetzt vom
eigenen ST alleinelassen mit der
Angst wenn du 16 oder 18 Stunden im
Bunker sitzt und die Tür nur mit deinen
Händen zuhältst bis deine Hand blau wird
dann wechselst du die Hand du hast nur
einen Baseballschläger dein Sohn sag
sagt dir wenn sie reinkommen dann schlag
zu das ist doch nicht das Leben dass ich
leben
will aber sie leben zum Glück sie müssen
jetzt stark sein fürüreinander
miteinander das ist Ihnen
bewusst ja es ist alles verbrannt was
sollen wir tun wir bauen alles von vorne
auf noch besser als es war es wird alles
gut es wird unendlich schwer ohne
Vertrauen in die eigene Führung
seit dem Holocaust dürften noch nie so
viele jüdische Menschen an einem Tag
ermordet worden
sein unfassbar und dann kommt heute
Abend noch diese Meldung aus eben diesem
kibutz da melden heute abend israelische
Fernsehsender dort sind mittlerweile die
Leichen von mindestens 100 Menschen
gefunden worden grauen und kein Ende
einer der wie kommen anderer die
Vorgänge rund um geiselnamen in Nahost
und die Verhandlungen darüber kennt ist
hat Konrad der lange für den
Bundesnachrichtendienst in Nahost
gearbeitet hat 2011 pendelte er zwischen
Hamas und der israelischen Regierung hin
und her wir sehen ihn hier mit
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu um die
Freilassung eines Soldaten zu erreichen
der 5 Jahre in Hamas Gefangenschaft war
schönen guten Abend Herr Konrad ja einen
schönen guten Abend das war damals mit
Gilad schalid für die israelische
Gesellschaft bereits eine aufwühlende
Zeit es ging um einen Soldaten heute
sind 150 Menschen in der Gewalt der
Hamas sie haben damals mitgewirkt an
diesem Austausch über 1000
palästinensische Häftlinge konnten nach
Gaza zurück ist sowas heute wieder
denkbar nun wenn es nach Hamas geht
wird es natürlich einen ganz
außergewöhnlichen Austausch geben
die Gedankenwelt von Hamas richtet sich
natürlich darauf zu sagen gilatchalid
war
1027 Häftlinge Wert der wir Hamas und
der palästinian Islamic Jihad wir haben
jetzt 130 Geißeln davon sind mindestens
30 wahrscheinlich mehr
Militärangehörige wenn sie nur allein
diese Gruppe nehmen und mit 1000
multiplizieren sehen Sie in welchen
Kategorien wir landen das sind im
übrigen Kategorien die natürlich völlig
unrealistisch sind denn ich
wageüberhaupten dass so viele Häftlinge
in israelischen Gefängnissen also
palästinensischeften gar nicht gibt die
von Hamas als Kämpfer bezeichnet werden
und es gab ja Herr Konrad auch damals
bereits in Israel viel Kritik an diesem
Austausch deswegen ist wahrscheinlich
auch undenkbar dass das heute
tatsächlich so noch mal statt finden
würde aber irgendwelche Optionen die
Israel jetzt hat was ist denn da denkbar
was was kann denn die Regierung jetzt
tatsächlich tun ja diese Art von
Hilflosigkeit hatten wir schon in einem
Einzelfall ja welche Optionen bleiben
übrig denn wie gesagt die Verhandlungen
mit der Hamas haben sich unter anderem
ja deswegen auch über 5 Jahre hingezogen
weil israelische Regierungen sich nicht
in der Lage sahen und willens waren
einen solchen Preis zu bezahlen jetzt
sind sie in einer wesentlich
schlechteren Situation äh und sie haben
natürlich die Verantwortung mehr noch
als Gegenüber gilatchalid gilatchalid
ist im Einsatz verwundet und entführt
worden hier haben Sie jetzt eine
Situation in der das
Sicherheitsversprechen des israelischen
Staates gegenüber seinen Bewohnern erst
einmal zeitweise zusammengebrochen war
das heißt die Schuldfrage wenn Sie so
wollen wer ist verantwortlich für das
traurige Schicksal der Menschen liegt
stärker denn je bei der Regierung und
damit auch die
Anforderung diese Situation zu lösen wie
auch immer und dieses auch immer hat
seinerzeit nicht zu irgendwelchen
Militäraktionen z.B geführt in der
Erwartung und der Befürchtung dass man a
den amelchalid nicht findet und B ihn
gegebenfalls sogar umbringt das ist
interessant was sie gerade sagen weil
wir erleben ja jetzt aktuell wir haben
es gerade von unserem Korrespondenten
gehört dass eine Militäraktion gegen
Gaza vorbereitet wird wie es sie
offenbar noch nie vorher gegeben hat was
heißt denn das aus ihrer Sicht für das
Leben der Geiseln geht das überhaupt so
eine Militäraktion starten und trotzdem
die Geiseln möglichst sicher waren äh
auf den ersten Blick geht das natürlich
gar nicht ne und Sie haben ja auch schon
die Drohung von Hamas äh gehört und die
wird man tendenziell ernst nehmen müssen
dass sie für bestimmte Angriffsformen
nicht also Angriffe Bombardements ohne
Vorwarnung so war glaube ich die
Formulierung eben anfangen würden geißn
zu erschießen das ist natürlich
auch auch eine nicht Lösung aber eine
Drohung mit der sie umgehen müssen als
israelische Regierung als Kräfte und
eine bodenoperation nie da gewesen
Umfangs wie wollen Sie mit der wenn sie
nicht zufällig und das muss man sehen
zufällig die aufentaltsorte der Geiseln
in Erfahrung gebracht haben dann können
Sie die auch nicht retten m das W sonst
die denklogische die denklogische
Konsequenz ja eine furchtbare Lage in
der die Regierung sich da befindet in
Israel Herr Konrad sie kennen die
hamasführer vermutlich besser als jeder
andere in Deutschland hätten sie denen
denn diese massive terroroperation die
wir jetzt gesehen haben zugetraut
äh von der Absicht her von der
Zielsetzung her ja dass sie sich
überhaupt erstmal operativ soweit
ertüchtigen konnten wenn ich jetzt lese
ich kann das ja auch nur Medien
entnehmen es gibt ja erste erste
Aussagen dazu dass man sich ungefähr
zwei Jahre auf diese Operation
vorbereitet habe planerisch und
natürlich dann auch in der Ausbildung es
war nichts was Heras aus dem Stand
heraus hätte machen können mhm ja eine
Frage noch mit der Bitte um eine kurze
Antwort bitte
was wie sehen Sie die Zukunft glauben
sie was kann aus diesem Krieg der da
jetzt läuft bereits und noch viel
stärker zu werden droht folgen am Ende
für den Nahen Osten nichts Gutes äh wir
werden
erhebliche Anstrengungen zur
eskalationsbegrenzung unternehmen müssen
alle von uns sowohl international als
auch regional
denn das Eskalationspotenzial ist
aufgrund der
beispiellosen Operation von Hamas ist
eben auch beispiellos nicht und der
Handlungsdruck auf Israel ist auch
beispiellos und insofern ist das Risiko
einer horizontalen Eskalation in der
Region erheblich sagt Gerhard Konrad er
war lange als Vermittler für den
Bundesnachrichtendienst im Nahen Osten
unterwegs Herr Konrad vielen Dank für
das Gespräch danke schön ja wir erleben
eine Dramatik von historischer Dimension
wir haben es gerade gehört der schwerste
Angriff seit einem halben Jahrhundert
auf Israel ausgehend von einer
islamistentruppe in Gaza die niemand als
wirklich entscheidend auf der Rechnung
hatte war es wirklich nur Hamas oder
haben da auch ganz andere ihre Finger im
Spiel der Verdacht fällt auf die
Machthaber im Iran und das ist nicht nur
Vermutung sondern zugleich auch
Befürchtung Jörg
Brase jedes Jahr am alkutztag
demonstrieren sie in Teran für den Kampf
der Palästinenser gegen Israel zuletzt
im vergangenen April nach dem Motto der
Feind meines Feindes ist mein Freund
feiert die Führung des schiitischen ir
jetzt den Angriff der sunnitischen Hamas
auf
Israel es ist die Manifestation des
Widerstands und des Aufstands gegen das
verlogene zionistische Regime man kann
dem palästinensischen Volk allen
Widerstandsgruppen und der islamischen
Gemeinschaft nur zu diesem Sieg
gratulieren im Internet kursiert ein
Video in dem angeblich die Führung der
Hamas Iran für dessen Unterstützung der
jüngsten Militäraktion dankt das ist die
Unterstützung gibt sei klar meinen
Experten anders als im Libanon und in
Syrien aber schicke Iran kein eigenes
Personal in die
Palästinensergebiete wir wissen dass
Iran keine Militärberater in Gaza
stationiert hat ich rede viel mehr von
Waffenlieferungen und finanzieller
Unterstützung der Hamas die Iran zur
Verfügung
stellt es sei sicher meintan Iran in den
Angriff von Samstag eingebunden war und
diesen gut geheißen habe seit
Jahrzehnten tobe ein Schattenkrieg
zwischen Iran und seinen Erzfeinden USA
und Israel so töteten die USA 2020 den
Kommandeur der Revolutionsgarden Kassem
solemani Israel attackiert immer wieder
iranische Atomanlagen und ermordete im
selben Jahr msen farisade den Leiter des
iranischen
Atomprogramms Iran sich für diese
Anschläge gerecht sagen wir wie es ist
und Israel wird darauf antworten aber
nicht im Rahmen einer offenen
kriegerischen Konfrontation mit Iran
sondern durch andere
Maßnahmen die iranische Führung warnte
heute vor einem direkten Angriff und
drohte Richtung
Israel wer immer die Islamische Republik
bedroht sollte wissen dass jede törichte
Aktion gegen die islamische Republik
eine verheerende Antwort erfahren wird
der erdzfeind Israel ist getroffen und
schlägt zurück gegen Gaza gegen die
Hamas aus der Luft bald vielleicht auch
mit Bodentruppen es ist ein Krieg bei
dem Iran wohl seine Finger im Spiel hat
den Blutzoll aber zahlen
andere wir bleiben noch beim Thema und
den Reaktionen jetzt in Deutschland mit
dir Hanna bundesentwicklungsministerin
Schulze hat erklärt die
Entwicklungshilfe für die
palästinensischen Gebiete auf weiteres
auszusetzen sie wolle mit Israel
besprechen wie die Projekte am besten
dem Frieden und der Sicherheit in der
Region dienen können sagte sie die
EU-Kommission kündigte am Abend an ihre
Hilfe für die Palästinenser lediglich
auf den Prüfstand zu stellen laut EU und
bundesaußenministerium läuft die
humanitäre Hilfe
weiter Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat
sich entsetzt über
Solidaritätskundgebungen und Jubelfeiern
für die Hammers in Deutschland geäußert
es könne nicht geduldet werden wenn auf
offener Straße versucht werde die
brutalen Attacken auf Israel zu feiern
sagte Steinmeier bei einer Veranstaltung
im Schloss belvü wer diesen Terror
bejubele trete die Menschenwürde und die
deutsche Verfassung mit Füßen so
Steinmeier Bundeskanzler Scholz und
Frankreichs Präsident macron haben
Israel ihre volle Solidarität
zugesichert zum Auftag der zweitägigen
deutschfranzösischen Kabinettsklausur in
Hamburg kündigten sie zu an am Abend mit
US-Präsident Biden und dem britischen
Premier sunak telefonieren zu wollen man
sei sich einig dass es nicht zu einem
Flächenbrand in der Region kommen dürfe
erklärte
Scholz fast 60 Mitglieder der Linken
haben einen
parteiausschlussantrag gegen Sarah
Wagenknecht gestellt dieser wurde bei
der Landesschiedskommission der Partei
in nordrin-westfalen eingereicht in dem
Antrag heißt es dass Wagenknecht
erheblich gegen die Grundsätze sowie
gegen die Ordnung der Partei verstoße
und ihr dabei schweren Schaden zufüge
Wagenknecht erwägt schon länger eine
konkurrierende Partei zu
gründen 32 Jahre nach dem Brandanschlag
auf ein Asylbewerberheim in saloui ist
ein heute 52-jähriger unter anderem
wegen Mordes verurteilt worden das
Oberlandesgericht koenz verhängte eine
Jugendstrafe von knapp 7 Jahren zum
Tatzeitpunkt war der Mann 20 Jahre alt
bei dem Attentat war der ganageche
Asylbewerber Samuel jeboa ums Leben
gekommen erst ende vergangenen Jahres
konnte der heute verurteilte gefasst
werden der Tag nach Landtagswahlen ist
in Berlin traditionell einer für Freunde
der Floristik da kommen die
Protagonisten aus den Ländern in ihre
Parteizentralen und egal ob Wahlgewinner
oder krachender Verlierer es gibt
meistens Blumen heute ist das Ganze weit
mehr als ein Ritual weil doch sehr klar
worden ist es geht ans Eingemachte
allein dass die in Hessen und Bayern
schwer abgestrafte FDP heute versichern
musste sie werde in der Koalition
bleiben sagt schon vieles Britta
buchalz an diesem Morgen will das
Klatschen im Konrad adenauerhaus kaum
enden fast 2we Minuten Anerkennung für
zwei Wahlsiege bejubelt wird auf jeden
Fall der hässische Ministerpräsident wie
viel Applaus davon dem CDU
Parteivorsitzenden gebührt unklar
polarisierte er doch mit Äußerung gegen
Asylbewerber ich habe für meine
Zuspitzung die ich gelegentlich dann
auch mal mache in Hessen und in Bayern
sehr sehr sehr viel Zustimmung bekommen
ich denke mal dass hat das Wahlergebnis
auch nach oben
mitgebracht gedrückte Stimmung dagegen
bei der SPD historisch schlechte
Wahlergebnisse der Traum der
Innenministerin häische Regierungschefin
zu werden platzt fraglich ob sich die
SPD nun stärker von ihrem Kanzler
absetzt die Klatsche bekommen aber alle
drei ampelpartner ihre Lösung mehr
Orientierung weniger Streit der muss
schon auch mal sein das ist in Ordnung
wir sind drei sehr unterschiedliche
Parteien mit unterschiedlichen
Geschichten und Herkünften aber am Ende
müssen wir uns einigen und das ist ja
auch was was die Gesellschaft als Signal
auch gerne haben will die Grünen sehen
das ähnlich fordern keine Kurskorrektur
die ampelhele erfolgreich Mahnung wir
haben eine Verunsicherung in dieser
Gesellschaft die uns verpflichtet dass
wir in den Mittelpunkt schieben die
wirtschaftliche Lage die Inflation die
Situation in der Ukraine und jetzt gilt
es das Recht für die ampelparteien dass
wir Vertrauen zurückgewinnen ein
bitterer Denkzettel auch für die
Liberalen und nicht der erste seit die
FDP im Bund mitregiert geht es Berg ab
der Parteichef lastet das auch der Ampel
an viele Themen
insgesamt muss man allerdings
feststellen dass die Koalition den
Erwartungen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nicht entspricht in den Bereichen
Wirtschaft
Migration Klima und Energiepolitik das
müssen wir gemeinsam miteinander
aufarbeiten aufarbeiten das klingt
bedrohlich doch die Schwäche der Ampel
stärkt die AFD Feierstimmung Weidel
sieht ihre Partei auch im Westen
angekommen um es in
der
Sprache des Bundeskanzlers zu
formulieren ist das Ergebnis in Hessen
und Bayern ein doppelwums gewesen der
bayerische Ministerpräsident will den
AFD Höhenflug nun beenden sein Rezept
die Reform des Asylrechts wir
appellieren dringend daran dass wir
jetzt einen deutschlandpakt gegen
unkontrollierte Zuwanderung brauchen wir
brauchen einen klaren Weg der
Deutschland bei dieser Frage zu einer
Lösung bringt die Ampel wurde abgestraft
und muss nun Bund weiter regieren es
dürfte noch komplizierter werden in
solch schwierigen
Zeiten fast ein Viertel der Deutschen
war gestern zur Wahl aufgerufen Hessen
und Bayern zusammen das steht für mehr
als regionales klein klein und so muss
man feststellen dieses Land ist nach
rechts gerutscht Wahlsieger AFD in
Hessen geht deren Erfolg auch zu Lasten
der SPD die bundesinnenministerin Nancy
fäer dort in historische tiefen geführt
hat Peter teisen geht dem nach Nancy
fäer heute Abend beim Landesvorstand der
Hessen SPD kein Kommentar mehr zur
Wahlniederlage 15% eine Demütigung die
Verunsicherung spürbar heute werden wir
erstmal die nächsten Schritte beraten
und auch glaube ich unsere mal
hoffentlich versichern davon gehe ich
aus dass wir eben stabil bleiben dass
wir ja die nächsten Wochen Monate
erstmal ja klare ein klarer
Ansprechpartner sind ich rate jetzt
davon ab irgendwelche schn Schüsse zu
machen sonder das Wahlergebnis muss im
Einzelnen angeguckt werden anderen Orts
mag so ein 15% Ergebnis schon normal
sein aber in Hessen früher eine Hochburg
der Sozialdemokratie mit
Ministerpräsidenten wie Holger Börner
und Hans Eichel und werden jenseits der
40%. es gibt Gebiete etwa in Nordhessen
um Kassel die galten selbst in
schlechteren Zeiten als sichere SPD
Wahlkreise auch sie sind nun allesamt
verloren
also die Schwarzfärbung der hässischen
Landkarte ist das Ergebnis eines
doppelten Wahlkampfes gegen Berlin
einerseits gegen die ampelregierung und
andererseits gegen eine der führenden
repräsentantinen in der ampelregierung
Frau fer und daraus resultiert dass
diese Wahl eigentlich keine Landtagswahl
war sondern eine zwischenwahl zur
Bewertung der Bundesregierung Damen und
Herren Szenen eines missglückten
Wahlkampfes nen sie fäer wird ausgebutt
in baunertal früher wäre das hier ein
Heimspiel
gewesen stattdessen viel Wut und
erstaunlich viele die hier früher SPD
wählten haben ihr Kreuz diesmal
ausgerechnet bei der AFD
gemacht die Macht des Populismus
schleicht sich auch an die sozialgruppen
heran für die die SPD traditionell eine
starke Zuneigung verspürt das sind die
unteren Schichten das sind die unteren
Mittelschichten und diese wanderungs
gung ist schon etwas bedrohlich weil es
ja bedeutet dass die SPD diese
Integrationsleistung gegenüber dieser
Gruppe nicht mehr so erbringen kann sie
nicht mehr glaubwürdig zu sein scheint
und in diese Lücke springt gegenwärtig
die AFD hinein die Migrationsfrage also
der Schlüssel um verlorenegangene Wähler
wieder an die Sozialdemokratie zu binden
es scheint dass ich diese Überzeugung
langsam auch in der Hessen SPD
durchsetzt Menschen müssen der SPD
wieder Vertrauen deswegen brauchen wir
in Berlin auch weniger Streit und mehr
Orientierung und Sicherheit das ist
eines der Rezepte und die AFD muss
entlft werden weil um deren Inhalte ging
es leider überhaupt nicht sondern die
waren einfach dagegen das hat
offensichtlich Menschen gereicht im
hässischen SPD Vorstand dürfte heute
abend heftig diskutiert werden man will
sich der CDU als Koalitionspartner
anbieten doch zur Zeit wirkt die einst
stolze hässische SPD einfach wie
gelämt interessanteak am Tag danach dann
jetzt die Börse mit dir Hanna ja und
dann blicken wir auf den
Wirtschaftsnobelpreis der in diesem Jahr
an die usökonomin Claudia Goldin geht
die Volkswirtin ist erst die dritte Frau
die mit dem renommierten Preis
ausgezeichnet wird und ihre Forschung
dreht sich auch zum Großteil um Frauen
Valerie Haller in Frankfurt wofür wird
die Harvard Professorin ganz konkret
ausgezeichnet ja ganz konkret für ihre
Forschung zur Kluft zwischen Männern und
Frauen in der Arbeitswelt sie geht
Fragen nach wie warum arbeiten Frauen
weniger warum werden sie meist
schlechter bezahlt eine ihrer zentralen
Thesen dazu Elternschaft sei eine
entscheidende Erklärung für die
Unterschiede Frauen neigten nach wie vor
eher dazu beruflich hinter ihren Männern
zurückzustcken meisten müssen sich
mehrere Wissenschaftler einen Preis
teilen golden aber ist die erste Frau
die ihn ganz für sich alleine bekommt
die 77-Jährige ist gebürtige New
Yorkerin Volkswirtin und Professorin an
der Elite
wo sie die erste Frau war mit einer
Festanstellung in vielen
Industriestaaten gibt es inzwischen mehr
Chancengleichheit der
Verdienstunterschied zwischen den
Geschlechtern sinkt in Deutschland
verdienen Frauen im Schnitt pro Stunde
aber immer noch weniger als Männer
18% nur in Österreich und Estland ist
der verdienstabstand in der EU noch
größer vielen Dank Valerie nach
Frankfurt heute gab es gleich mehrere
Auszeichnungen für ZDF Kollegen die
Terra x Moderatoren harald Lesch und
Mirko drotschmann erhielten das
Bundesverdienstkreuz für ihren Einsatz
für mehr Bildungsgerechtigkeit und
moderne Wissensvermittlung auch ZDF
Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf wurde
ausgezeichnet für ihre Arbeit in der
Ukraine und Afghanistan erhielt sie am
Abend den Augsburger Friedenspreis die
Journalistin stehe beispielhaft für
einen Berufsstand der zu den tragenden
PIL dann unseres Gemeinwesens gehöre
hieß
es ja wir sagen Glückwunsch an die
kolleginn die Kollegen und Danke schön
an sie fürs zugucken heute an einem
weiteren schweren nachrichtentag und der
ist noch nicht zu Ende ja denn später
gibt's noch unser heute journal Update
um 0:05 Uhr mit Christopher wermann wir
sagen ein angenehmen Abend tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend zwischen dem Tief Ralf und
dem Hoch Tora gab es heute noch ein
bisschen Regen der löst sich jetzt mehr
und mehr auf dann Streifen die
Regenwolken vor allen Dingen die Küste
Norddeutschlands und das ist ein richtig
kräftiges Tief dieses Tief Ralf das
sehen Sie hier an der windvorschau für
Mittwoch da sehen sie nämlich dass es da
richtig stir wird über der nördlichen
Nordsee besonders spannend aktuell sind
aber die Temperaturen die lagen ja heute
zum Teil bei bis zu 28° am oberrehein
und diese Wärme wird noch gesteigert bis
Mittwoch dann wird es auch in
Norddeutschland noch ein bisschen wärmer
werden und apropos Wärme auch die
Nachttemperaturen sind zurzeit
ausgesprochen mild mit 14 bis 7° heute
Nacht fällt zwischen Berlin und dem
Bayerischen Wald noch etwas Regen im
Westen ist es häufig klar da bildet sich
auch mal etwas Nebel und morgen ziehen
die Regenwolken ostwärts ab neuer Regen
kommt von der Nordseeküste heran aber
die Grenze zum freundlicheren Wetter
verschiebt sich immer mehr in den
Nordosten und so ist es morgen im Süden
und Südwesten strahlend sonnig und do
morgen erwarten uns 28° am oberrehein
häufig sind das Werte über 20° im
Nordosten bleibt es bei 16 bis 19°
kühler und am Mittwoch kommt Regen von
Norden heran am Donnerstag erreicht er
Bereich die Mitte der Freitag wird dann
in Norddeutschland stürmisch und wenn
Sie sich fragen ob das irgendwann mal
kälter wird es könnte tatsächlich Anfang
der kommenden Woche mal für kältere
Temperaturen reichen dann wird die
Strömung auf norddrehen wir warten es ab
auf
Wiedersehen